Traduttore: Marco Caresia
Revisore: Andrea Giglio
È molto bello essere qui, anche se,
per grande parte della scienza,
non avremmo dovuto esserci.
In effetti, durante l'era glaciale,
avremmo dovuto trovare
la nostra estinzione,
invece, mi pare, a giudicare
dal numero delle persone che vedo,
che non è andata così.
Sono venuto a raccontarvi quella
che io ritengo essere una bella storia.
Una storia di una specie magnifica
che ha avuto tanta paura.
Quindi vi parlerò della loro paura
- che poi, in effetti,
è anche la nostra paura -
e poi vi parlerò della mente.
La mente che, in questo incessante
tentativo di farci sopravvivere,
non esita a imbrogliarci.
Infine vi parlerò del coraggio.
Il coraggio è una cosa
che abbiamo inventato
per difenderci da noi stessi.
Io ho paura;
come homo sapiens ho tanta paura.
Qualcuno mi ha chiesto:
“Ma cos'è questa fissazione per la paura?
Perché ti interessa così tanto la paura?”
Io sono formatore, un educatore,
ho lavorato per tanti anni
con i gruppi e con le persone singole.
Ho scoperto quanto la paura
possa essere capace di bloccare
tutte le nostre aspirazioni.
La paura ha il sapore
del metallo sulla lingua.
Ricorda un po’ quello del sangue,
non so se avete presente.
È qualcosa che veramente può disturbarci.
La peggiore di tutte è
la paura della paura.
Funziona con i pregiudizi, preconcetti
e le preoccupazioni.
“Pre”, appunto, prima che succedano,
e fa venir fuori
quelle vocine che sentiamo
e che io, in questo momento, sento:
“Lascia perdere, vai via, non è il caso!
Ma sei sicuro che puoi
hai abbastanza informazioni?
Ma dai che non ti piace? Non è per te!
Dai, ti guardano tutti!”
Ecco, questo è un meccanismo complesso
e anche molto semplice.
Il meccanismo funziona più o meno così:
la nostra mente recepisce dei dati,
degli stimoli dall'esterno.
Immediatamente scatta un allarme
e inonda il sangue con sostanze
che ci fanno reagire.
Le reazioni sono di tre tipi.
La prima è: scappare;
la seconda è: combattere
e la terza è: bloccarsi.
Ecco, devo dire che questa nostra mente
lo fa per proteggerci,
ha un grosso interesse
a farci arrivare a fine della corsa.
Ma è anche un po' egoista,
perché pensa a se stessa.
Pensa a proteggere se stessa,
a consumare poche energie,
ha questo istinto di autoconservazione
e, per fare questo, non esita a mentirci.
Ci manda delle immagini
che non sono la realtà,
non sono la verità.
Per esempio, io cammino in un bosco;
vedo un ramo dalla forma sinusoidale
a terra e, immediatamente,
ecco l'immagine di un serpente!
Mi proteggo, ma non è la verità,
è una bugia.
In questo modo la nostra mente
può trasformarsi in un’entità bloccante
e, in qualche modo,
diventa un pessimo padrone.
Mi chiedo e vi chiedo
se non vi è mai capitato
di cercare di fare la scelta giusta,
la cosa giusta.
"Faccio la cosa giusta, ci penso.
Pensaci più volte prima di agire!"
Ma cos'è la cosa giusta in assoluto?
Ogni volta che scegliamo,
lasciamo da parte altre cose.
Quanti di noi, a causa della paura,
non portano sulle spalle
qualche rimorso o qualche rimpianto?
Bene, per capire come funziona
tutto questo
mi sono permesso di tornare indietro
nel tempo
e vedere come l'evoluzione,
in qualche modo, ha condizionato
questa storia.
Ricordate che il coraggio
lo abbiamo inventato
e lo abbiamo inventato proprio
per difenderci dalla nostra paura.
Parliamo del nostro antenato,
l'homo sapiens, 100.000 anni fa.
Vivevamo in un ambiente naturale
abbastanza confortevole:
un bel po' di risorse a disposizione,
qualche predatore di troppo,
ma comunque si viveva una vita decente.
Poi, improvvisamente, dei cambiamenti
climatici repentini
- repentini si fa per dire,
perché si parla di ere -
hanno trasformato il nostro ambiente
naturale da così a così: la savana.
E nella savana non ci sentivamo
più tanto a nostro agio:
c'erano molti predatori e l'homo sapiens
non voleva fare da pasto a leoni e iene.
Così, per qualche motivo inspiegabile,
70.000 anni fa, ha deciso
di puntare verso Nord ed è partito.
Un viaggio incredibile,
un viaggio verso l'ignoto,
verso l'incertezza:
un viaggio di 70.000 anni, pensate!
Diretto verso Nord alla scoperta,
affrontando l'ignoto.
L'ignoto diventa un'opportunità.
Con loro avevano tanta paura
e qualche attrezzo o utensile di selce.
Niente più.
In 70.000 anni si imparano
però tante cose.
E l'homo sapiens ha voluto sempre
esplorare ed innovare,
finché alla fine non ha trovato
il continente Europeo
e lì ha trovato una culla
dove, in qualche modo, fermarsi,
ma sempre continuando
ad esplorare e innovare.
Poi, 40.000 anni fa, probabilmente
durante una battuta di caccia,
si imbatte nel suo cugino più
sofisticato e anche più affascinante:
l'homo di Neanderthal.
L'homo di Neanderthal
è forte, è veloce,
è perfettamente adattato ai climi freddi,
è un predatore incredibilmente efficace.
E i due, per un po' di tempo,
Condividono tante esperienze
e, probabilmente, anche un po' di DNA.
E cosa succede?
Che adottano comportamenti
completamente diversi.
I tempi sono duri per tutti,
ma l'homo sapiens decide
di praticare il nomadismo:
non si ferma mai,
non si accontenta di quello che ha,
vuole vedere dietro le montagne,
cerca la Grande Acqua, esplora.
Il neanderthal vive in una piccola zona,
la sfruttra al massimo e,
quando le risorse vengono a mancare,
l'abbandona.
Sapiens osa unirsi ad altri individui,
esterni al gruppo familiare
e quindi rischia anche un po'.
Questo per scambiare conoscenze
e crea le prime proto-tribù.
Neanderthal invece: gruppo familiare,
poche persone, pochi individui
e, ovviamente, soffre
dell'impoverimento del codice genetico
e della mortalità femminile.
Sapiens innova sempre: sembra
incessantemente interessato a migliorare.
I suoi utensili cambiano e diventano
sempre più sofisticati
e anche le tecniche di caccia.
Neanderthal, invece, per migliaia di anni
fa sempre le stesse cose.
Infine sapiens inventa il linguaggio:
un codice sofisticato che serve a
scambiarsi la conoscenza e saperi.
Neanderthal non ha molto da condividere
e quindi: sapiens sopravvive;
neanderthal si estingue.
Darwin,
il nostro amato Darwin, aveva ragione:
è la specie più capace di adattarsi
al cambiamento a sopravvivere
e sicuramente lo fa a spese
di quella più forte.
E così è stato dal punto
di vista biologico, ma non solo:
anche dal punto di vista
dei comportamenti!
I nostri progenitori hanno avuto
il coraggio di adottare
comportamenti sociali nuovi
ed efficaci in un contesto
di continuo cambiamento,
come quello dell'era glaciale.
In ogni homo sapiens, proprio in tutti,
esiste un'innata spinta ad osare
per affrontare la paura.
Noi siamo una specie che ha
un'incredibile capacità di desiderare
e questo ci espone all'incertezza.
Dopo di me, su questo palco,
sentirete storie incredibili:
persone che si sono perse
in oceani in tempesta,
altri che stanno immaginando addirittura
un viaggio su Marte,
persone che hanno sfidato malattie
molto serie e inabilitanti,
e lo hanno fatto sempre senza cercare
l'assoluta sicurezza,
perché l'assoluta sicurezza impedisce
il soddisfacimento
delle nostre aspirazioni.
E allora sono venuto qui a dirvi
che nella mia esperienza professionale
ho scoperto che la paura
ha un'origine biologica
e sarà sempre con noi,
non si può eliminare.
Non possiamo non avere paura.
Il coraggio, invece, è un'altra cosa:
il coraggio è una competenza.
Il coraggio si impara,
il coraggio si allena,
il coraggio è la quantità di incertezza
con la quale siamo disposti a convivere.
Se noi coglieremo quest'opportunità,
riusciremo a crescere
e fare del cambiamento
una vera nuova chance.
In questo modo mi potrò permettere di dire
che la mia mente da pessimo padrone
diventerà ottimo servitore.
E allora, in questi tempi di incertezza,
dove questo mondo sembra andare talmente
veloce da non potergli star dietro,
tutto cambia e siamo un pò
sopraffatti dagli eventi.
In questi tempi, credo che sia utile avere
una donna e un uomo nuovo:
neo sapiens, appunto,
non più homo sapiens.
Non abbiamo più bisogno di altri muri,
di filo spinato, di leggi
che regolano tutto quello che ci circonda,
non abbiamo bisogno di unirci
in altre tribù che combattono
nuove tribù sotto simboli antichi.
Sapiens sopravvive ad ogni simbolo
e ad ogni ideologia.
Non abbiamo bisogno di tante abilità
e nuove tecnologie,
quanto di avere empatia
ed esercitare comprensione.
Ci serve umanità.
È tanta roba, ma, tranquilli,
queste cose non dobbiamo farle da soli.
Guardatevi intorno: chi sono
queste persone sedute vicino a voi?
Chi c'è in questo teatro?
Girate la testa, guardateli!
Chi sono tutti questi?
Perché sono venuti qui oggi?
Perché avete scelto di dedicare
Questa giornata al TED?
Con chi avete scelto di venire al TED?
Questa è la nostra tribù!
Questa è la tribù con cui dobbiamo
imparare a riunirci di nuovo,
ma veramente, come hanno fatto
i nostri progenitori.
È importantissimo imparare,
ri-imparare a comunicare con profondità
e a condividere i nostri bisogni.
È importante essere generosi
e condividere i nostri saperi,
mettere le competenze al servizio
di una grande tribù.
Ma, soprattutto, è importante
avere il coraggio di cambiare tutto.
Se riusciremo a cogliere
questo insegnamento,
se ci riusciremo,
avremo un'opportunità.
E, per questo motivo, io vi dico
che la grande opportunità di crescere
e di progredire, per la razza umana,
passa attraverso la necessità
di accettare l'incertezza.
E, in questo modo, ci riusciremo,
come 70.000 anni fa, come sempre.
E allora vi chiedo:
qual è la quantità di incertezza
che siete disposti ad accettare oggi?
Qual'è la sfida che volete raccogliere
oggi, in questo teatro?
Darwin aveva ragione:
se non cambio mi estinguo.
E questa qui è la chiave
della nostra sopravvivenza.
Grazie per aver ascoltato.
[Applausi]